good morning
that Sun is bright this morning it's a
nice balmy 40 degrees out this morning
good morning girls you're filling up
that tote pretty well they're nice and
long come on in
good morning yeah good morning
it's amazing how fast they grow that's
the meat birds food not your food one of
the things I love about where we live is
it's 40 degrees up right now it's nice
and chilly it's gonna be in the 70s
today for a high place be able to wake
up make BRR
I'm cold push punch it on with some
shorts and it just feels nice Rufus the
meat birds are doing awesome and they're
growing great these are
freedom Ranger meat birds
and this tractor we have our new egg
layer group the red ones are no virgins
and the other colored ones are our
Easter egg players they'll be laying
some like blueish green eggs for us we
have one rooster which will go in the
crock-pot
I've been working on our goat milking
stanchion we got it all built so much I
think about what I want to finish it
with I'm gonna go to our what we always
trust and use is tung oil and mineral
spirits
[Music]
[Applause]
we ended up losing one of the turkeys we
don't know why they're all doing great
ever since we've had him Juno blast I
was like hey I think one of the turkeys
dead I'm like what I was just down there
and they were all fine
so keep our fingers crossed that we
don't lose any more I only wanted two
turkeys and I got four because I know
turkeys can be very finicky when you're
raising them as babies and then once
they get bigger and feather it out
they're very Hardy it's just at this
stage they're not which is odd I had to
pick up some grain while I was out today
afternoon girls you're getting a good
nap in what you're doing what
[Music]
yeah
you're doing mister you keeping an eye
on the kid you keeping an eye on the
chickens
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a crazy dog
[Music]
nope I'm not goin over there when I'm
working with an oil finish I like to
store everything outside and in a sealed
bag afterwards
believe it or not I applied oil finishes
furniture at the furniture company I
have seen spontaneous combustion on
oil-soaked rags there are outside in a
bucket and the bucket was in the Sun
they get so hot and they just died on
fire
[Music]
Jaina made a nice delicious meatloaf
yesterday just put into the oven and
bake it for dinner tonight
[Music]
it's made with ground pork from our
picks that we've raised this winter and
yet it's gonna catch up topping
[Music]
yeah 80112 acres hey guys to run
homesteading c5 by
[Music]